[Musik]
ein priester ist er nicht aber ein guter
zuhörer als solcher erteilt er ihr die
absolution einer frau die den weg aus
ihrer sucht sucht stellan skarsgard
spielt in einem vermerk den weißen
seligmann charlotte die sexsüchtige ja
in einem vermerk ist viel sex zu sehen
aber erotisches der film nur ganz selten
stattdessen zeigt lars von trier den sog
der ekstase der show zum junkie macht
die triebfeder des lebens von ihrer
zerstörerischen zeit
[Musik]
als vix vorlage würde ich diesen film
nicht braucht wer einen porno erwartet
wird ziemlich enttäuscht sein
interessant ist nun von maniac vor allem
in geschlechterfragen schon die junge
giro lässt sich in keine rollenklischee
press sie pfeift auf die liebe männer
sind mittel zum zweck
natürlich gilt unersättliche appetit auf
sex als maskulin eine eigenschaft die
man viel eher männern als frauen zu
bestehen von trier und die frauen das
ist spätestens seit dem horror drama
antichrist ein minenfeld charlotte haas
bucher spielt hier eine frau die sich
voller lust hingibt und dafür gnadenlos
bestraft wird
nur ein paar glücksmomente lang
vernachlässigt die junge frau ihre
aufsichtspflicht die strafe folgte auf
dem fuß ihr sohn stürzt aus dem fenster
[Musik]
weil sich die frau schlimme vorwürfe
macht verfestigt sich in ihrem kopf die
verheerende idee sex ist böse und das
weib des teufels werkzeug ein uralter
waren der mittelalter zur verfolgung
abertausender frauen führte antichrist
spaltete 2009 bei seiner premiere in
cannes das publikum
lars von trier sei frauenfeindlich
behaupteten seine kritiker die reaktion
des politisch unkorrekten regisseurs
blieb nicht aus denn damals nahmen noch
persönlich zu seinen filmen stellung
ich glaube nicht dass man durch den
wegen den himmel hinauf führen kann oder
ähnliche wunder die ware provokation des
films bestand arbeit seiner fokussierung
auf die hexen natur der für das böse
weil das war eine bewusste provokation
meinerseits
als das dänische rohr vor terrible 2011
in cannes ankündigte seine depression
szilagyi mit einem porno abzuschließen
musste darum böses erwartet werden zum
aller gleichzeitig behauptete ein nazi
zu sein
seither hält von trier bei öffentlichen
auftritten die klappe auch auf der
berlinale wo die ungeschnittene fassung
von dem vermerk premiere feierte folgte
er seinem schweigegelübde trieb ist
keine sünde sondern das was uns antreibt
von der gleichung frau + 6 gleich böse
ist in lars von triers informiert
glücklicherweise nichts zu spüren
und als ob der kontrast zu antichrist
nicht schon stark genug wäre endet
dieses werk des nervenkitzels so viel
seife
gar mit einer feministischen porte
[Musik]